cas besoin 20 26 e mail à ce que pour me
le prêter
et bien me le prêter alors il vous prête
de l'argent
25000 dollars parce que vous allez lui
chercher du pain j'ai pas dû me c'était
vous pouvez pas nous dire que vous avez
pas utile si c'était le cas je n'ai pas
à lui mais j'ai pas fait j'ai pas
allumée est en train de nous dire que
vous étiez un baisser les incompétents
écoutez je pense pas être imbécile je
pense pas est incompétent non plus je
peux définitivement pour parfait soit
c'est une danse auront un certain nature
mais quelles sont les choses que vous
vous dites que vous vous semblait
hésiter à dire non mais j'hésite parce
que oui vous préférez confrontés mais
s'il ya quelque chose que vous saviez et
j'ai oublié je vous l'admettre mais une
chose que certaines vous savez puisque
nous sommes ok parfait ce que vous avez
dit de ce que monsieur pères où il
demande à monsieur meunier demande juste
aux orioles et amateurs cela valait de
montage monsieur lalonde est un menteur
mais chez les cadets l'état mental et
nous vous en êtes pas vous avez menti
tout à l'heure lorsque j'ai posé la
question est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu parler d'un disait collusion à
montréal n'ont pas 20 la commission donc
là on vous attends rien ne dit qu'une
arrivée tellement bien entendu parler
que vous avez posé de nombreux gestes
pour essayer d'y répondre
c'est ça vous n'y êtes là là maintenant
quand vous pourriez vous l'appelez pas
les mêmes passé mais finalement vous
voyez pas grand chose et que vous des
gens qui sont corrompus puis on vous en
parle pauvres avaient fréquenté un
génial kippa décote mais on vous en
parle pas m'ont vu fracasser beaucoup
jeu qu'on peut croire de façon statique
que monsieur trépanier ce qu'ils
appellent la journée même d'un comité de
sélection aussi souvent ou sinon le
lendemain que c'est pas pour parler des
résultats du comité de sélection sous
lequel vous faites partie c'est vraiment
que du hasard
à 19h55 le matin n'ont pas le choix de
22.9 rage à faire vous repassez vous
vous croirez sur cette strophe 6 à notre
place
j'affirme qu'aucun maire n'aurait pu
mettre au jour et faire cesser la
collusion comme l'escouade marteau et la
commission ont réussi à faire je n'ai
jamais fait d' aveuglement volontaire
je regarde parce que ce que j'ai fait
j'en appelle clémence de la population
générale aux payeurs de taxes de
montréal je regrette amèrement
j'aurais jamais dû accepter ces montants
là j'ai résumé 10 face aux esquisses est
la bonne manière de faire des choses non
si gérard à la fresque d'ouvrir notre
foi noms du sport pierre ce que j'ai
fait mais les rues mais je ne peux
effacer le passé ni les événements
auxquels j'ai participé ce c'était le
psy possible petit bois parce que
j'aurais voulu l'arrêter à mama puis
j'ai essayé d'arrêter je me sens partie
fautif le je les dis ici j'ai fait des
bisous monumental le pire ennemi des
mandats très éco après courtrai en
direct vos subi des conséquences de mes
gestes
c'est pas d'autre choix que d assumer à
partir de 2005 et 2006 via un montant de
3 % des contrats que moi je remettais un
monsieur milioto que j'avais
connaissance que ce montant là à les uns
aux partis politiques du maire tremblay
monsieur trépanier même en dérapant dans
son bureau ce que j'ai fait mais
diffèrent n'a pas fermé la porte et d'y
fermer soit votre secours j'ai fermé les
stades
trépanier était derrière son bureau
penché il était devant son coffre-fort
judy ben gardane henri fam pub parce que
trop d'argent dedans sont des finances
peau on et aux proches des élus sont
n'est pas proche des élus dont peut pas
s'attendre et aidants
dans les films qui ont été vite et on ne
peut pas s'attendre à avoir des mandats
c'était le contexte actuel c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionnait